this home is truly the jewel of the  desert  it is sitting in mcdonald highlands and  dragon ridge overlooking the entire las  vegas valley and the strip  uh it is on close to two acres  unobstructed views  it is an amazing house full of energy  and life we have a lot of  celebrities moving here athletes and  they are looking for something custom  something that's personal  that they can relate to and feel  comfortable with you literally have a  zero inventory almost one month supply  in all  levels all price ranges it's it's  amazing that our city went to sleep  almost for a year  and now everybody's out buying homes the  interest rates are incredibly low  this particular home it's fun it's  exciting it's very vegas  it's got a touch of rock glam yet it has  a wellness spa  as you saw that brings the life outside  in we have pocket doors everywhere so it  breathes it has life